[Music]
all right
who likes moving houses is it a fun
process for anyone i don't know anyone
that likes a little oh like moving
right now i don't know that's stressful
i like helping my friends move really i
don't even like doing that
i kind of actually i actually like that
dude i like i like it i like i like just
uh seeing how fast we can move stuff in
the into the truck
and then like thanks for your help by
the way that day we moved we did it in a
day
dude joe joe was like hey can you help
me move and by the time i got there
it was like everything was moved right
and he was like here take a bunch of
stuff and i was like okay thanks and
then that was it
i was joking hello two new best friends
i hate moving i just moved oh nice
horrible horrible yeah i hate you
you probably got a huge house with a lot
of things you probably have like fancy
stuff to like carry out
she has a whole tyrannosaurus rex
[ __ ] like
skeleton she's like yeah can you guys
help me move this i used to have a truck
so i felt responsible to move
people like my friends because i was
always the guy with the truck yeah but
now i have a mini cooper because i was
sick of it
in college all of my friends just got
into fish tanks and [ __ ]
i'm like [ __ ] son and bart also had like
a
race truck too that he didn't want his
bed scratched up
so i'm like why would you get a truck if
you don't want to put anything in your
truck
because it's for coolness hey bart i got
into saltwater fish bro
uh yeah this weekend pal let's go
oh my sweet jesus and it's like race car
paint and it's all nice and stuff
you're like hey dude like it's not for
that here's the thing i can't empty the
water
we're just gonna have to carry it
downstairs
all right so since we hate moving so
much would you guys
ever find yourselves moving to 18
different homes in the course of three
years
to make your partner happy no god no no
[ __ ] no
no but my wife is high maintenance
already holy [ __ ] god
dude this person is living in a parallel
universe in one year
three years six years six places and six
places
in one year one year that's every two
months yeah every two months
how much stuff do you even have how many
neighbors do they disagree with
and are they breaking the lease every
time or are they like going through
escrow every time we're on the run
that's a great question i have no idea
so this story comes to us from
india oh maybe they have different rooms
i have no idea what the rules are
then witness protection they're like
all right so uh the husband uh
he first became aware of his wife's
phobia of cockroaches
right after the wedding in 2017. oh oh
if every single house has this roach
infested then it makes sense yeah
it does make sense keep moving into
[ __ ] roach motels well the thing is
you know when you have a new house uh
you don't move into a home that's got
roaches in it right when you first move
in
hopefully it's a clean nice home that
you're moving into
but over time and i guess we're also in
la so it's
a dryer here so the climate doesn't
really give us a whole lot of pests
like say in florida you know or like
hawaii i'm sure
you're more likely to get you know
little critters
crawling around wait wait wait la has
[ __ ] tons of roaches i promise it
depends where you go huh depends on
where you go
the sewer next to my house has a [ __ ]
ton dude there's a [ __ ] ton
everywhere i've lived there i've seen
[ __ ] tons really really
well not currently in your home until
my most recent residence yes oh [ __ ]
okay at some point
so what's happening is they get into a
new house and then it's fine for a
couple months and then a roach appears
and she's like we got to get out of here
we're moving
exactly oh but there has to be something
maybe
that's attracting the roach if it's her
maybe it's hershey if something keeps
happening over to you and you're like
you have a roach thing
no i mean do i am i scared of revolt
yeah i mean
are you like let's [ __ ] move i don't
know if a roach like crawled right
across the table and just
stopped right there would you scream
first or like i don't know
scream but nikki has a phobia of roaches
for sure let's start swinging bro
they are nasty looking people they say
you don't really just move keep moving
right but they don't bite you could just
grab them and throw them
yeah bro but just the way their shape
looks weird they're disgusting looking
for sure i don't want to kill them
because they stink when you kill pretty
fast too actually yeah they're hella
fast
they're the only [ __ ] that
actually climb up on your arm as you're
trying to get them like they're not
afraid of you yeah they'll climb up on
you i will freak out if they
if it's right here i'll if it's on me
now that's reasonable i'm going to war
with roaches who eats them that's what i
want to know
i don't know i feel like that's a crazy
question friends in mexico they
defraud not like humans but like what is
their predator all right
like cats like birds birds they're not
lizards some
unsuccessful predator frankly because
they've existed for thousands of years
yeah even they don't want to eat them
they're like ooh that's not i pass on
the roach man
oh yeah maybe that's why they get the
bad rep of being disgusting because even
other predators don't choose to eat them
yeah they do stink though you know they
don't smell good when you kill them how
do we introduce these guys to lions
yeah lions [ __ ] everything up yeah i've
never seen a lion lose
true every nature documentary i've ever
seen well maybe
maybe it's up to us to eat them what
about frogs frogs you can't bring a lion
to house
yeah [ __ ] we need to take that one out
right release the frogs
yeah awesome lions chameleon
i think i think like lizards would be
eating them but this is too small
yeah but like big lizards komodo dragons
yeah that's what it is we got
komodo dragons lions can handle it yeah
and they're photogenic
yeah and they're they're majestic dude
it's very fun
you can't do it too much or it gets
banned yes it does
so are they still married all right so
yeah so after three years after three
years of having moving
18 times uh during the course of this
the husband has tried to get his wife
to go to therapy for this so apparently
there's a name for this it's called
catsaridaphobia and it's the fear
cockroaches and he's been trying to get
her to get into uh treatments for this
and she's now claiming that uh her
husband is
uh declaring her mentally ill and she's
putting up a fight and saying i'm not
doing therapy you're calling me mentally
ill
that's not fair the husband's had enough
and he's filing for divorce
oh but i mean dude he rolled with her
for 18 years old pretty sick that's
really
that's pretty commitment he really tried
yeah he really tried i think by
the first home yeah i'd be like are we
really moving because of a cockroach
exactly i wouldn't i don't know if i
would ever find myself moving just for
the sake of bugs don't they say like
moving is
one of like the top five biggest
stressors of someone's life
you know i mean it has to be it is so
stressful
so there's only one after one not like
the mummy style or like
oh oh true like like do you think like
the one or is it like a lie in the house
that's a good point
because there's one i don't get but
maybe there's like a lot it's an
infestation
so it's like like are they little cgi
guys going all
wobbly all right they're not going
through your mouth
coming out your ears and [ __ ] i get her
i get hurt but after
you know oh i'll move as many times as i
think i need
therapy these things come out of my
[ __ ] mouth and go into my ears
get over it [ __ ] he's like what the [ __ ]
you're so dramatic
traps in india you know those roach
traps those little things where they eat
it and they spread
spread the food to the rest of the
colony and they all die
they don't got those that's cool we
should mail them something maybe they
have the flying kind of roaches too
because the ellie roaches are not
airborne you know yeah
they haven't invented aerodynamics yeah
different countries it's i'm sure that
the roach demographics are different you
know they might need to move out of the
country go somewhere
like dry us buck you know that's true
what country doesn't have roaches
nowhere right roaches survive anything
they they they think
alaska alaska maybe they need to move to
alaska
you know survive the nuclear holocaust
if there was a nuclear war
like the whole world just got decimated
cockroaches would actually survive that
yeah that's [ __ ] dude
no you're [ __ ] no i mean like that
sucks that like that
that survives like that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] dude get rid of them bro
oh my god out of all the science that we
have we haven't figured out a way to get
rid of roaches
i want to see that i want to see them
put a roach in a controlled nuclear
explosion
yeah yeah and then they go see the [ __ ]
you folks
like do they [ __ ] told you on its
back and their legs go
and then you're like and
[Laughter]
yeah but i killed a roach with raid
before so i'm like if it can't survive
raiding i'm not about
nukes bro yeah i think that's [ __ ]
no we'll see i tried to spray lysol
because that's the only thing
around it didn't do anything did the new
[ __ ] do anything we kept going
it's like thank you for making me shiny
i smell
fresh i thought that would do something
they adapted
dude get rid of what is the purpose of
that because like i know
ants like that you know they collect the
little crumbs in the trash
but what what the [ __ ] do roaches do
they same thing they help decompose
things
huh they're part of the decomposition
process they decompose uh
plastic straws as they do all of those
like okay
no apparently they don't yeah the
turtles are like no they don't bro
[ __ ] no they're not doing their job
yeah we need them to get all the plastic
bottles yeah damn let's throw them on
that plastic
island yeah and they'll just eat that up
yeah that's what we should do i know
it's another
the big berg yeah in the middle of the
ocean oh my god you have the trash
we did an article before about um
[ __ ]
someone farming roaches on an island
and then they took these roaches and
they would actually cook them and grind
them down into powders and create
proteins or something like that
yeah and his biggest problem was he got
too much [ __ ]
he was just drowning and fussing that
reminds me of a [ __ ] snow piercer
remember that movie oh oh wait it was no
piercer
he couldn't go anywhere oh
those those bars that they were eating
spoilers that's
that's uh that's our that's our future
roaches man he kills those because
straight tens were coming out of
non-stop yeah
you could couldn't handle the pressure
yeah
just if you guys want some [ __ ] just
start forming roaches
you guys need some girls out there man
yeah something gets a little white
faster than [ __ ] farming roaches
no if nikki sees a roach because on one
of our first dates
we actually were in we're in hollywood
and i
accidentally stepped on one and we heard
the pop
oh yeah and she like freaked the [ __ ]
out and to this day
all i have to do if we see a roach i
just say pop and she [ __ ] has a blood
curdling scream
is it the same way with spiders too no
she's cooler about spider-man she freaks
the [ __ ] out for sure and she's like oh
my god
spider-man fighter but it's it's not the
same as roach roaches are just nasty
yeah roaches are gross bro
but i have to save spiders because my
sister
loved i mean she's a vet so she had she
made me save
all animals and insects even roaches
everything dude
i couldn't kill anything or my sister i
like spiders because i eat all the other
bugs yup
if i have a daddy long leg i keep them i
like their little mosquitoes yeah
they don't bother you this day if i like
just two nights ago i had to get a
spider
every time i hear it ah spider i have to
take it outside or else i'm an [ __ ]
oh you know those massive
mosquitos they're like gnats or whatever
yeah when they come in i'm like yeah
because they actually eat the mosquitoes
and other bugs oh yeah
but did you guys hear this does i don't
know if it's a myth they said that
average every person
has eat like five or six spiders i heard
of that too
yeah because they call in your mouth
yeah they go in their mouth and sleeping
i'm a mouse reader so i probably double
that
i want brag but rolls like is it true
though or is it a myth
i don't think it's true because i used
to sleep with my sister and
she never noticed she never noticed
spiders corn in my mouth at all
sorry you got me at the whole i used to
do something
i stopped listening afterwards you all
were waiting what do you think i wasn't
gonna do it
you think i wasn't gonna do it really
yeah come on dude
final shot of the baby you're talking to
steve you all got 12 rounds with anybody